l'éleveuse de la semaine la story qui a
fait le plus parler celle d'un cadeau de
rêve sur une plage qui s'est transformé
en cauchemar sur les réseaux pour
l'anniversaire de ses 28 ans nabila a
décidé de poster sur les réseaux sociaux
le très joli sac offert sur une plage
paradisiaque par son mari et père de son
enfant
thomas vergara un sac réputé pour être
le plus rares au monde appelait
l'himalaya confectionné par la maison
hermès en peau de crocodile cette pièce
exceptionnelle coûterait la modique
somme de 33000 euros
un cadeau impressionnant que beaucoup
d'internautes ont eu du mal à comprendre
si beaucoup ont dénoncé le prix excessif
de ce sac accusant même le couple
d'avoir acheté un faux d'autres ont
attaqué nos visas sur son engagement
pour la défense animale pour eux un sac
en croco ce n'est pas très militant de
son côté l'animatrice laurence boccolini
a également réagi à cette story qui fait
beaucoup parler parfois je me filme en
train de vérifier s'il a des lcd vache
qui rit dans le frigo sont encore ban
bref un bad buzz colossal alors selon
vous en at on trop fait autour de ce sac
[Applaudissements]
euros hermès a offert non il a payé il
ya une facture il est vraiment acheter
on a tout entendu au final personne ne
sait et vous vous serez tous d'ici la
fin de l'émission
on a toutes les infos mais d'abord
guillaume à des interventions courtes
s'il te plaît comme ton sexe vraiment vu
[Applaudissements]
ce sac d'école il sait qu'on est en
effet univoques du débat donc les années
80 voyage en angola
c'est par une le cerveau ça c'est
impossible mais ça arrive beaucoup c'est
ou non alors par du sac de nabila
[Rires]
s'échelonnant années 80 dans les années
80 john bertille et en avion et elle se
trouve en face du président jean louis
jean louis dumas ou d'hermès et elle
vient d'avoir sa petite charlotte
gainsbourg et elle dit c'est très chiant
ya pas de sac à main un peu jolie
élégant et pratique pour mes affaires et
celui de ma fille et il lui dit si vous
voulez on n'a qu'à dessiner un sac et
donc dans l'avion paris londres 40
minutes qui décide un petit 50 ans il
fallait qu'ils soient comme ci comme ça
où ça donc on a donné le nom vers
tallinn à ce sac est devenue iconique
qui vaut en cuir 7000 euros
ouais il faut six mois d'attendre pour
l'avoir tellement il est demandé dans le
monde entier et qui vaut en crocodile
33000 euros
et là me donna de magali nabila qu'avait
dit à quelques moi j'adore les animaux
j'ai vu un documentaire donc je vais
vendre toutes les fourrures peu des
aliments est battu c'est que elle vient
de s'acheter ce sac à 33000 euros alors
que il ya six mois elle disait je suis
pas là on va regarder cette vidéo
effectivement en crise et que maintenant
le voulez et vous les protégez la cause
animale mor fadam reçu un sac en
crocodile regardez la vidéo
j'envisage de devenir végétarienne
plutôt végétalienne parce que je ne veux
plus manger tout ce qu'un des animaux
donc les oeufs le lait tout ça tout ça
j'ai regardé à peu près sans vous mentir
une dizaine de reportages en fait le
traitement des animaux ils étaient ils
étaient juste affreux le réchauffement
climatique
il y aurait apparemment un énorme
pourcentage qui serait dû au fait des
élevages du bétail voilà de tout ça ça
aimé du gaz est donc en fait ça
participe beaucoup au réchauffement
climatique et créaient encore de prendre
l a dit
j'envisage mais depuis qu'elle a vu deux
sacs elle est plus pour la protection
des animaux
est ce que oui ou non alors d'abord
effectivement guillaume bien de dire il
vaut 33000 euros 100 euros en or ont en
fait deux parents par la note de parents
parce que c'est des crocodiles qui sont
des crocodiles albinos très bien et très
difficile à faire
donc on comprenne bien comme c'est des
sacs très rare vous pouvez si vous payez
vous le payez 33000 euros
mais comme c'est très rare après par la
spéculation sur des sites sur internet
il peut monter jusqu'à 120 mille euros
et la version diamant ou le fermoir et
en diamant on peut monter jusqu'à s'est
vendu chez christie's à 304 mais là on
avait droit de cent mille sept cent
mille maintenu 33000 euros toi c'est
vrai on transfère 33 qui dit mieux les
vraies infos maintenant magali berda
c'est sa meilleure amie elle fut d'abord
un oui ou non lui offert ou est-ce
qu'elle l'a acheté alors c'est thomas
qui vient faire il l'a achetée il a payé
son argent tomar est un influenceur qui
a très très bien sa vie un très grand
influenceurs
xamax n'y a pas de données de prix non
plus so lu ment pas elle a eu zéro
réduction
enfin il eu la vie dure aux rédactions
chercher ne savait pas c'est une
surprise totale et ça fait des années
qu'elle le voulait ça faisait des années
que les calanques alors rêver et quand
il était allé chez hermès effectivement
pour son anniversaire
les vendeurs y ont dit ah bah on a celui
là on l'a on l'a reçu donc il lui a pris
puisqu'il sait que c'était son rêve il a
voulu faire plaisir à sa femme donc
magali s'ils ont reçu et qu'il a acheté
cher à m forcément comme il a deux
parents et que dieu m'a eue les prix
officiels elles il a payé 33000 euros
mais alors voilà je vais être honnête
avec vous je pense que tu n'as pas les
bonnes informations
je pense qu'il vaut un peu plus que ça
maintenant après je sais pas combien
vous obliger à payer si c'est parce que
ma vie chère mais j'y suis allé
spécialement combien vole haut niveau le
l'himalaya voilà on dit 33000 euros
après vous pouvez le trouver à 60 80
alors mis la russie a des infos puisque
tu as annan a tué d un ami toi aussi qui
a le sac c'est ça oui alors
effectivement après c'est vrai que quand
il sort directement de la boutique je
pense qu'ils coûtent beaucoup moins cher
absolument voilà est assez rare à
trouver effectivement les prix
augmentent même dans les enchères comme
au japon jusqu'à 380 mille euros moi
j'ai une copine à moi donc qui a été
enfin on lui a offert ce sac son mari je
pense pas que ça venait de la boutique
il a eu aux enchères il a eu pour 80000
euros
d'accord très bien mais ce qui prouve
bien qu effectivement une vraie prise
autour de trading en avant moi ce qui me
choque c'est qu'on fasse une polémique
autour du prix alors par rapport aux
animaux la cause vegan
comprendre ce que c'est complètement
contradictoire par rapport à ce mode de
vie ça je le conçois que certaines
personnes puissent est énervé en
revanche qu'on en fasse toute une
polémique autour du prix sachant que kim
kardashian possède déjà ce sac les
femmes de footballeurs et notamment une
femme d'un rappeur et que ce soit nabila
qui prend un petit peu toutes ces choses
juste parce que sinon influence aussitôt
mail en vue d'offrir un cadeau à cent
mille euros de notre groupe on se
comprend pas ce qu'on comprend pas ce
qu'on comprend pas me lasser qu'on s'est
tous dit si elle louvre elle ouvre son
cadeau cesse devant comme ça en faisant
coucou en ciblant hermès est le pire des
cas une photo d'elle où elle a tous les
sacs hermès qui sont qui sont alignés
dans l'escalier une vidéo par dont on a
du mal à croire que plus étrange à les
regarder
regardez on ne peut pas croire que à
mettre sa seconde ce rythme le bilan
risque le plus a tranché
mikhalkov qui est le relations publiques
d'hermès mais qui pose avec thomas donc
très content dans la boutique avec le
sac dont allaoui se met en avant en
avant on se demande alors il faut vous
sachez qu'elle collectionneuse des
fermes et elle se paye elle n'a aucun
avantage ou cas de ce bref autant brin
faut donner l'info qui est véridique
j'ai vu son dressing je sais je connais
son dressing ou alors les voir dans la
vidéo mais je peux vous dire c'est
impressionnant c'est sa passion des
centif nabila elle vit en montrant sa
vie c'est sa vie c'est comme ça son
métier et m
effectivement elle reçoit un cadeau de
krems à elle le montre où est le
problème
mais moi je suis dit alors y'a pas déjà
il faut dire que si c'était sponsorisés
ça c'est la loi on est obligé sur les
choses et instagram de le mettre
d'après la question qu'on s'est posée
c'est vrai c'est que hermès est partie
des marques les plus chics qu'on va dire
françaises
j'adore nabila n'est pas la fille la
plus chic au monde puisqu'elle permet
s'associe totalement non mais à la demie
qualité je trouve cette idée mais moi
pareil je suis pas dans ce qu'on appelle
le petit parisien chic ça c'est pas une
des arts en cas d'ailleurs donc oui
pardon monsieur mathieu oui je trouve
que je connais un petit peu le sujet
pour une raison simple c'est en fait ma
femme est directrice de la pub d'un
grand magazine féminin
oui et elle connaît bien hermès hermès
faut savoir c'est que l'on va rater
tutelle à marc collat dior finaux voilà
justement c'est une marque ou quand vous
travaillez des sens entrant dans cette
entreprise il bauxite et le mot luxe
vous insulte hermès estime ne pas
apparaître avec la messe
ouais bah je vais le lire et à bord et
il estime
faire de l'artisanat la française sire
que jamais jamais il ne médiatise un
placement produit jamais c'est contraire
complètement leur édition sur un sac en
bulgarie où il risque d'avoir des
problèmes
comment tu expliques que le gars de la
com et posé avec l'auto mars je pense
qu'il ya une histoire effectuant ce que
tu dis ils ont dû se rencontrent en
vacances faire un truc cynisme dans la
boutique
non et c'est pas mais 16e répressif ce
qui pose avec son maintien avec le
secteur devrait faire ce qu'a fait jane
birkin jane birkin a demandé à ce qu'on
retire son nom d'une marque son nom de
ce site sac là quand elle a vu les
conditions d'abattage des crocodiles et
elle avait dit à l'époque mon sac je les
vends et je donne l'argent à la
croix-rouge anglaise wayne nabila devant
la polémique absolue que crée ce 6 que
crée ce sac puisqu'elle aime tellement
les animaux mois qu'elle achète un sac
je m'en fous c'est juste qu'elle peut
pas dire je ne peux pas dire je descends
les animals et après les jo
d'abord pour la défendre je crois
qu'elle pensait quand même on a la peau
ils sont des cons que devrait le vendre
à des bois c'est son cadeau
d'anniversaire chine huit ans visait
qu'à la vente cette fourrure kelly
magali la série noire elle envisage
devient béganne parce qu'il veut
protéger des animaux et l' homo il ya
d'autres émissions on a montré comment
tuer ces animaux pour le truc c'est un
coup de couteau s'est inversée dans la
plaie dos on découpe tout comme ça et
retire la peau n'ont jamais connu parce
que dès qu'elle pense quelque chose elle
le dit elle et l'oubli c'est pour ça que
les gens l'aiment c'est parfait les
natures et parce qu'elle joue pas le jeu
il me magali magail et la grèce ne
dépende pas que du coup il va traiter du
coup le décor est là pardon excusez moi
je comprends que ce soit mal interprété
du coup dans quand elle dit qu'elle veut
devenir vegan et qu'après il ya un sac
aux locaux je comprends que certaines
personnes soient énervés j'arrive à le
concevoir
en revanche c'est un cadeau nous on
n'est pas elle qui l'a choisie vous
voyez ce que je veux dire son mari est
supposé la connais je sors avec
quelqu'un je suis qu'il est vegan juin
offre pas un animal man mais là
uniquement des médias et de certaines
personnes sur les réseaux comme laurence
boccolini qui sont jaloux et frustré
thèmes à traiter
non tu déjà tombé dessus tu vois c'est
que le traité sa villa franchement il
n'y avait rien du tout ils étaient très
contents pour elle les seuls qui ont
râlé c'est des journalistes ou mais
c'est tout magali c'est pas laurence
boccolini qui a inventé le tweet de
maguette de me2 si elle avait rien et on
n'aurait rien dit mais elle est allée
faire des tweets pas possible sur nabila
c'est que franchement est si elle
regarde etc
oui même à gagner comme ça c'est pas
leurs mots clinique a inventé le fait
que magali né un jour je suivais ganet
lendemain reçoit un cadeau encore être
chances de nabil enfin un pétard contre
nabil a contraint dhabi là c'est juste
que voilà c'est un exemple pour la
jeunesse et c'est dommage ce soit cet
exemple là maintenant la réussit son
coup on ne parle que de ça ça j'ai des
reds ça a généré 2 millions de tweets
c'est moi qui m'ont eu un petit peu mais
je sais pas si c'est vrai c'est que il
paraît qu'un habile est très heureuse de
toute cette histoire de plus devant
tourner autour
parce qu'évidemment ça fait un buzz
incroyable on gagne des followers et du
coup on gagne de l'argent et on rachète
des crocos et on achète des éléphants et
je peux te dit choqué oui alors je
choqué parce qu'on en a trop parlé oui
après choqué par le fait qu'elle soit
d'un trophée en fait oui c'est ça on en
a trop fait on a parlé de plein de prix
on à paris cette histoire pendant des
jours et des jours sauf qu'au final bon
ben voilà c'est son cadeau des nerfs
très bien oui on en a trop fait et puis
qu'on peut passer comme ça tu meurs
c'est que quand c'est que quand ce sont
des hommes qui collectionne des voitures
de luxe et mâchant dit jamais rien là
c'est encore une fois
alors les postures les voitures c'est
l'écologie aussi là-dessus voiture de
l'intérieur est entièrement revient sur
une des photos de diva pour que tout
soit en cuir est illégale alors je
verrais bien un moment donné on est bas
oui mais alors mon nom va tout s'en va
référente on a bossé que des chaussures
emploi même pas rendu les armes
ces beautés à pied et puis j'ai juste eu
métro et je bois que vous dire c'est
très classe quand même moi j'aurais de
renaissance c'est en ça que c'était
intéressant justement ces histoires de
sac parce que ça a relancé le débat sur
plein de choses sur l'écologie sur
l'argent facile sur le côté de chauffe
aussi parce qu'à côté on trouve un peu
arrogant de monter cette réussite et cet
argent il faut ça ça peut être un peu
violent après tu trouve ça bien les
choses que tu peux quand même pour les
gens ses followers est passé rempli
euros pour un prêt c'est qu'un trade
show
du coup ça avant ce débat surtout sur
l'argent facile et les gens sur
l'écologiste josé ganis millet pas
d'embellie c'est que au lieu de refaire
baron nous nous avons offert un cadeau
comme ça on offre hors caméra on
l'aurait pris tout simplement oh mais tu
leur été sacré chez vous parce qu'on a
le sondage regardait ce que vous êtes
choqués on a trop fait ou pas c'est la
question oui à 50 balais s'intéresse et
jean battault mieux parce que c'était
notre débat du jour
maintenant c'est castaldi longue vie à
tous